our once green and pleasant land has
been sapped of color from grass in hyde
park yellowed to crop fields harvested
weeks ahead of schedule due to the heat
the risk of fire is heightened this a
grass fire in raynham in essex
chris sparks from hampshire doesn't know
how the fire started in his yard
all right so it's spread all through the
roof yeah
get in
good god but it had soon devoured a
bedroom wall and then his roof
the whole house is destroyed timber
frames charred
shoes melted as is the television i saw
smoking flames coming from the
uh
timbers
she ran round
tried to put it out and actually she
couldn't put it out and
called the fire brigade and next thing
we had
was 10 fire engines
um
breathing apparatus all up in the roof
knocking everything down trying to
control the fire and it was five and a
half hours later that they eventually
got the fire out
yesterday a tractor caught fire here in
codford in wiltshire
fire risk is another setback in a
difficult summer for farmers
it's the emotional effect and it's a
stress
and it's it's also the danger to to
to human life and uh
our staff are very dedicated and they're
very keen to fight the fires and
sometimes we we have to
tell them to ease off of it because i'd
much rather have a fire than a than a
than a staff injury
with some areas of the country not
receiving significant rainfall all
summer the national drought group
declared an official drought in eight of
its 14 areas of the country it means
more hosepipe bands and residents and
businesses being asked to conserve water
so the important thing is that the water
supply remains resilient for this year
there's no
no real issue there and these are
precautionary steps that are being taken
to ensure that we're taking care of our
water resources in case we get a dry
winter and then run into potential
problems next year
people here at the flower pots pub in
hampshire say they do what they can
when you've got a garden you put quite a
lot of money into it and it's all shrubs
and you're sitting there with one
watering can but what i have been using
is old washing up water anything at all
is going into the garden at the moment
it's tough trying to be a bit more
environmentally friendly obviously where
the hosepipe van not using water having
showers
not using baths what's needed is a wet
autumn and winter to restock reservoirs
such as this one in west yorkshire but
with soil so dry it will take consistent
rainfall to resaturate and get the water
levels back up
jason farrell sky news